is this God dancing?
skrattar du förlorar du mannen
(You laugh, you lose everybody)
welcome everybody to the first episode of skrattar du förlorar du
You're part of history. Congratulations to join in on this challenge remember to smash like right now in this video if you laugh you will lose
Jump into it it's over the phone rings and this boy says
There's this video I
Swear to god
the dumbest
Will get me every time it's not even funny. That's the thing. I'm gonna know Glen the second. It's over the phone rings
and this boy says
No, okay. All right. I may have laughed a little bit just a tiny bit
But it doesn't count. It doesn't work like that. I have three health bars. You have zero don't make me get angry
No, I got nothing. All right lamp leaves are just cranky that was last week's meme Wow
Sheis you know over there. Yeah Coolio. Gee I
Haven't even watched Jojo I know shame on me. I'm not allowed to be part of these memes
I've shared this video five times already. Come on everyone. We have an announcement to make so
I
Thought it would be something else
I thought they would add in something else, but I guess not I guess like we have an announcement to make
My heart hey sweet I can't
It's too innocent I can't up up and away with
Sam Pizza time
What time is it guys it's
Pizza time
Make sure you sign the petition. Let's have Tobey Maguire in the next spider-man. Oh
Yeah
All right, let's check my health bar
Wow looks like I'm doing great. How are you doing?
leave a comment down below not to feed a video more algorithm metrics to make it positive for more views and
Recommendation just because I'm curious how you're doing immediately the probe began recording a strange
Song coming from the comet's surface described as a drilling or clicking noise
It confused experts who to this days. All right. What is it gonna be it could be
Okay, basically a monkey it could be a mockney
Some scientists believe that the magnetic field surrounding the comet caused the sounds but what is this sound?
No, no no no no
Anything but that Sam anything but that sounds not really a pumpkin no
Monkeys are terrified. I know what in the frickin world was that basically a pumpkin no
Lore just cuts out
Yeah
Wow
Now I have this vocal cords
This is the crack version of pyro
Why is ben shapiro
Peek meme right now. Can someone explain this betcha pair up? We need ben shapiro hosting the next meme review. That's the only way
Let's keep going guys
Wow, it looks like i'm going great that must mean this video is garbage. This is so sad
Can we still hit 500 likes? Thank you. That's right
I still put memes that are over years old that became unfunny and dead for long time
I don't need friends. They disappoint me
Why wait, what's the original here we go carla shaw
carla shaw everybody. Hi. My name is carla shaw
Jesus
Does she do better help review? So my god, that's terrifying and you can try online therapy
You can stop at five or six stores or just one. Oh my god. I don't need friends. They disappoint me Oh,
Better with each it slaps vegana. I don't need friends. They disappoint me
I didn't see where she put the hand. Come on. What's your emergency?
Okay, stay where you are we're gonna send someone over right now you do not have to do
If there's a dog it could be rabid do not approach it
So is everything okay? Oh, yeah
Okay, great
May I ask how does a dog into your house? Well, I thought a doggie door last week is another one
Oh, come on here Oh
Greg Arnie
This is so wholesome. Oh, look, it's the clip again
What are they gonna do? everyone we have an announcement to make?
Okay, marzia sent me this one
Dad windows driver update great ad. what's the point of being alive?
Follow me to the window son look look out there. What do you see?
Moon huh stars, this is boring
Look closer my child you will see the answers you seek. I see something I
see a
grilled cheese
It's a good point the first Tea of the day
PlayStation 1
Why do I feel so uncomfortable peeking
Okay,keanu reevs smile he does have lovely lips a bass drop
Elicit kinder eggs. Yes, you're getting their
Traps
(100% makes you gay)
That's right, son that's right, that's right
That was amazing, it's much like if you think traps is you know
Let's end the video there guys looks like we're out of time
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if you did skrattar förlorar  leave a like
I don't know why I keep feeling like something does it even do anything? I don't even care
What I do care about however is money merch available limited time check out in description
Thank you very much main review and revise a YouTube favorites
Zero deaths everybody
( this meme is back!!!)
Special thanks to Niler for making this horrible subs ( please finish this subs I'm still at school ) (i did am karthik BTW)
buy ASS for $3.99!!
Why is this empty space here. Holla at me Subreddit!